And as Al said, I'm going to talk about talquetamab and it's sort of gloss half empty, gloss full.
You know, actually, when I was putting it together, I realized I should probably change the title.
I don't know how many people see Mel Robbins or Jay Shetty.
It should just be everybody's got something, right?
So you have to just figure out how to make the gloss half full.
So I don't need to really go into this in terms of GPRC.
I think Dr. Goddard this morning sort of nicely outlined GPRC expression in many tissues.
And Dr. Rolgaas is going to talk about it even more extensively in terms of the oral toxicity.
But just to say, of course, it is expressed highly on myeloma cells as well as other tissues, certain other specific tissues in the body.
So now let's talk about sort of the gloss half full.
And really it is in terms of VLA.
Look at this.
This is the long-term result, a monumental one, which, to remind you, was in patients with advanced disease,
meaning of about five prior regimens.
You see rapid responses.
You see in patients, especially patients who get complete remissions, very long durations of responses.
I wanted to highlight even more that on the bar graph, I don't know if we have a pointer on this or not.
Well, on the far right is the group of patients who had prior T.
Cell receptor therapy.
And I think that's very important because as we think about how we sequence drugs, the fact that you do get responses in about 60% of patients with a PFS of about seven to eight months in that group of patients is significant.
And sort of to keep in mind as we move ahead.
If you look at the other part of this is in terms of toxicity profiles, and certainly, you know, this is on the top graph patients with or without oral toxicity.
You do.
You see initial decrement in weight, but you can also see a general recovery.
And I think some of that was learning curve as well.
Now that we have learned to better manage some of these toxicities, one can hopefully abrogate some of that initial, even initial weight drop.
The bottom curve, I think, is another very significant part, which is the grade three infection profile is very different than what you see with BCMA bispecific.
So even a baseline.
The incidence is very low.
And of course, as you go further on into treatment, it drops even further.
I'm not going to spend too much time, but just really talk about skin and nail effects.
And this is from the Mount Sinai group.
Thank you guys for those slides of, you know, because I think now we're all very comfortable with managing the skin toxicity.
We warn patients about it.
It's generally self-limited, at least for us.
I don't know you guys, we don't send anyone to the dermatologist anymore.
We just, you know, topical measures and occasionally systemic steroids.
But even then, it's pretty rare to see such a significant grade three rash that we need to give systemic steroids.
But certainly, if needed, we've done that.
A little bit about the nail talks.
You know, again, strategies.
Most importantly, warning patients.
Again, this is from the UCSF group in terms of strategies they use and we talk to patients about.
I did want to note this.
An interesting thing.
Which is, there have been a couple of patients, and I'm interested to hear you guys, where we gave, I gave talcretin at post-CAR-T, and I did it as sort of a consolidation for people who were PET-positive.
They had some initial nail toxicity that resolved, I gave it for a short duration, about six months, stopped it, and then a couple of these patients I've seen now a year later, still in remission, but interestingly, they've all come and said, "My nails grew back, and now they're all falling off again."
And I don't know if that's a immune effect.
I'm interested to hear in terms of just, you know, other people's experiences of using, because we heard this morning about bispecifics post-CAR, and if it's just your immune system reconstituted a year post-CAR, and you see some of this, but again, I thought that was just very interesting as we learn how to use this.
I'm not going to talk about this because Mark is going to speak about this in great detail, the Discusia management.
You know, generally right now, our strategies have really been, of course, supportive care, dose modifications.
Either reducing the dose in the weekly or more commonly going to biweekly, and, you know, I've been fairly quick once patients get deep responses to go to monthly dosing.
So, of course, this is not the end of the story of how we're going to use talcretumab, and the future is really going to be ideas of fixed-duration combination therapy.
So, if we talk about combination therapy, you really need to think, is there a biologic rationale for this?
Can you use drugs that have non-competing toxicity?
And I think the biggest challenge that we have, and I'll speak about this in a tiny bit, is how do we overcome the resistance problem?
So, you know, again, here's all the multiple combination trials.
The one that stands out the most to me is the TRIM-2 study, TALDERA, that Ajay Chari published in Blood.
The reason it stands out is it did allow patients who were CD38 refractory, about 40 to 50%.
And it was a very good study.